[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
ce nouveau numéro de 7,8 débat la ligne
18 doit-elle se faire
la ministre des transports elisabeth
bornent à assurer la ligne 18 arrivera
dans les yvelines
il n'y a pas de doute sur ce sujet fin
de citation pourtant ce super métro qui
sera réalisé en deux phases et inscrit
dans le projet du nouveau grand paris
devant relier paris saclay en passant
par versailles ne met pas tout le monde
d'accord
d'un côté les partisans pour ligne
d'utilité publique est un mode de
transport performante de l'autre les
associations riverains et élus hostiles
au projet est soucieux entre autres de
préserver le plateau agricole
alors oui ou non la ligne 18 doit-elle
se faire à quelles conditions et comment
c'est le débat du jour est avec nous ce
soir pour en débattre
olivier paréja élu municipal europe
locaux écologie les verts à guyancourt
et conseiller communautaire à saint
quentin en yvelines nicolas dainville
conseiller départemental des yvelines et
arme smith responsable du colosse
collectif d'associations autour du
plateau de saclay et membre de
l'association des usagers des transports
bonsoir à tous les trois sont sur ce
plateau
je me tourne vers vous nicolas d'un viol
pour entamer ce débat va se débat
concertation et concertation autour de
cette future ligne 18 grande
mobilisation des élus en faveur de cette
ligne qu'est ce qu'elle représente 2,6
fondamental pour le territoire
mais vous l'avez rappelé effectivement
il ya eu un certain nombre de
mobilisation des élus récemment encore
abus en cours avec madame le tarnec le
maire de guyancourt donc c'est une
mobilisation des élus de tous bords
politiques
c'est bien qu'il ya quelque chose
vraiment de très important c'est très
important pour les habitants
parce que on a
besoin de mieux desservir notre
territoire c'est très important pour les
entreprises pour qu'elles puissent
continuer à se développer c'est très
important aussi au regard des événements
internationaux qui vont avoir lieu
on a les jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 on a peut-être
l'exposition universelle de 2025
sur le plateau de saclay donc au regard
de ces trois raisons essentielles
c'est vraiment important qu'on puisse
prolonger cette lune 18 et le plus tôt
possible dès 2024 avec une gare donc à
saint quentin en yvelines et puis
jusqu'à versailles chantiers en 2025
alors le plus tôt possible
quand même à 2024 l'horizon quand même
loin parlant alors c'est effectivement
un horizon lointain mais il faut la
construire
l'horizon pour cette chanson là ça 2030
jamais et evans 2020 car nettement c'est
vous qui l'a avancé cette demande des
élus c'est qu'il se fasse le plus tôt
possible
la vue des jeunes gp qui est 2030 qui ça
c'est très très optimiste parce que 2030
le dire qu'il ya aucun dérapage
alors répondre aux besoins des usagers
non à mon avis c'était une très mauvaise
solution pour un vrai problème mais le
problème il est mal formulé mauvaise
solution dans le secteur qui me concerne
le plus là où s'implantent de classeurs
paris saclay
les besoins sont pas du tout couvert les
vrais besoins ne sont pas couverts par
cette ligne là les vrais besoins se
s'articule dans un sens nord-sud les
habitants et des usagers du plateau dans
ce secteur là habitent dans les parages
8 yves sur yvette a amorcé à bure
lisbourg tout ce que vous voulez il
n'habite pas paris
ça ne représente les parisiens ne
représente que 20% des usagers donc on
faire là on est sur les deux côtés est
sur le côté ouest
je pense qu'il n'y a aucun besoin de
faire un une liaison rapide capacitaire
entre l'est et l'ouest
qu'il y ait des besoins à l'intérieur du
bassin de vie saint-quentin versailles
certes mais ça n'a rien à voir avec la
ligne 18
en fait ce qui intéresse les gens de
versailles c'est de relier versailles au
futur quartier de satory
c'est tout ce qui les intéresse tout le
reste c'est du cinéma et donc à qui
profitera vraiment s'aligne donc elle
profitera oui je me demande bien à qui
elle va profiter le métro tel qu'il est
conçu c'est une infrastructure très
lourde c'est à dire que un métro c'est
fait pour transporter 40 4000 personnes
par heure c'est à peu près la capacité
d'un métro donc ce qui fait que l'on va
on avait on va mettre sur le plateau de
saclay une capacité de transporter 300
400 mille personnes par jour aujourd'hui
il ya cent mille personnes sont mis
actifs à peu près cent dix sur saint
quentin en yvelines donc aux assises de
la mobilité la semaine dernière
gerpinnes leurs tiroirs a fait une
présentation très intéressante qui
explique que le bassin de vie de saint
quentin en yvelines s'étend aux communes
limitrophes donc par exemple versailles
donc ça veut dire que les cent mille
personnes qui actifs sur saint quentin
en yvelines
il y en a à peu près un quart qui reste
dans sa commune un autre quart qui va
aller travailler dans les onze autres
communes de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
et puis un petit peu plus et donc on a
un total de 58 % de personnes qui vont
travailler sur place dans un bassin
élargi saint-quentin versailles et donc
ça veut dire qu'il ya à peu près 45 de
personnes ces deux chiffres de l'insee
en 2013 45000 personnes qui ne
travaillent pas à 50 qui qui sont actifs
mais qui ne travaillent pas à saint
quentin en yvelines et ses quarante cinq
mille personnes principalement ils vont
à la défense ils vont à montparnasse à
paris ou sur rambouillet donc c'est les
principales destinations de ces
personnes là et aujourd'hui par rapport
à ces quarante cinq mille personnes qui
quittent l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines pour aller
travailler ailleurs
on va leur proposer un métro mais qui
peut presque tous les transporter en une
heure c'est totalement disproportionnés
par rapport aux besoins et nous qui nous
inquiète c'est que cette façon
d'aménager le territoire c'est à dire on
va continuer à faire ce qu'on a fait
dans les années 70 80
on a mis les villes nouvelles et
maintenant l'urbanisation a continué en
tache d'huile à s'étendre autour de
paris et maintenant toutes les villes
nouvelles qui ont été créés dans les
années 70 80 sont maintenant rejoints
par de l'urbanisme on est avec le
plateau de saclay à la limite de des
terres agricoles et à un moment il
serait peut-être temps qu'on change de
modèle de développement et que l'on ne
met pas une infrastructure qui fait que
dans 20 ou 30 ans
le plateau de saclay sera complètement
urbanisées alors que et on l'a encore vu
avec des déclarations à la coop 23 on a
besoin de relocaliser de l'agriculture
de proximité
tout le monde demande de l'agriculture
de proximité tous les 10 minutes en
france il ya un hectare de terres
agricoles qui disparaît et on ne peut
pas continuer éternellement a concentré
toute la richesse au même endroit donc
une infrastructure surdimensionné et
équipe recchi qui prédispose à une
urbanisation que nous ne voulons
absolument pas sur les trajets nicolas
d'avis sur ce terme une
une urbanisation surdimensionné ce que
vous êtes d'accord il ya un autre terme
qui m'a marqué vous parlez de changer de
modèle de développement
et c'est vrai que on a des routes qui
sont totalement saturés
on a vous l'avez dit oh moi j'ai des
chiffres un petit peu différent mais
c'est à peu près trois quarts des
salariés de saint quentin en yvelines
qui n'habitent pas le territoire donc on
a des routes congestionnées
et donc on a besoin d'eux d'alternative
en termes de transport et se donne 18
qui se retrouveront fin de l'année si
les régimes sociaux nés en exil et moi
mais les routes qui sont congestionnés
et on l'a bien vu dans le diagnostic du
projet de territoire qui a été remis il
ya quelques semaines les routes
congestionnées c'est principalement les
nationales c'est principalement la douce
et blessés parmi d'autres la nationale
10 et la nationale 12 effectivement la
départementale 36 sur le lac totalement
saturé est un peu saliver mais on saute
le pas du tout et même plus mais il ya
donc un vrai une vraie attente de la
part des entreprises on à 145 mille
emplois sur saint quentin en yvelines
on a des entreprises de grande taille je
pense à airbus à thales au technocentre
de renault qui ont besoin d'une
infrastructure nouvelle pour continuer à
se développer sur le territoire pour
mieux desservir cette zone surtout pour
leurs salariés pour que ce soit plus
facile pour réduire le temps de trajet
domicile travail
mais j'ajoute et si vous le permettez
intérêt du point pour rebondir ce que
vous venez dire sur effectivement le yen
paris saclay qui un des plus grands
sujets d'importance pour les années à
venir pour notre pays la france
killzone d'excellence pour qui va
représenter 20 % de la recherche
française qui va être une sorte de
silicon valley à la française
si vous avez lu la réponse de la cour
des comptes va rayonner dans la télé je
peux me permettre de terminer mon propos
pour pour réussir on peut être
pessimiste mais si on veut réussir ce
projet là il faut bien relier les
entreprises au laboratoire au campus
universitaires qui sont plutôt à l'est
du plateau de saclay donc il faut qu'on
réunisse cc l'ensemble des zones du
plateau de saclay c'est donc moi c'est
aussi pour ça que
bah son département réussir le yen paris
saclay qu'en face les transports en
commun sur le plateau de saclay
aujourd'hui ce qu'on attendait mais on
sera d'accord sur le mais après il faut
faire des transports en commun adaptés
aux besoins
aujourd'hui on a des bus qu'on n'a même
pas été depuis des années que la
communauté d'agglo de saint-quentin
existe on n'a même pas été fichus de
finir le transport en collectif en site
propre dans des lignes des voix sur la
route dédiée au transport en commun on
n'a même pas été encore capable de le
faire
alors donc l'utilisent arrière sur les
transports existants tout à fait tout à
fait il faut on peut y aller très
graduellement c'est à dire on peut on
peut déjà faire que les bus soient
efficaces aujourd'hui ils sont bloqués
dans les embouteillages
donc faisons déjà que les bus et leur
propre voie et soit efficace
ça c'est une première chose on peut
augmenter la capacité des bus avec des
bus à haute capacité de service je ne
sais plus exactement comme ils
s'appellent mais des bus qui soit
beaucoup plus direct et qui répondent
aux besoins
les gens qui sont dans les entreprises
et qui veulent aller à orly ça
représente pas des flux qui nécessite
d'installer un métro qui fait 4000
personnes à l'heure où la demande des
entreprises
elle est allée très forte vous
connaissez également mais ces
convergences mais c'est sur la nécessité
de transport on se met d'accord il ya un
vrai sujet un vrai problème de transport
malgré tout les vies nous les
innovations et avec le pead est d où ces
plans de lentilles fier ce vrai besoin
ce soi-disant vrai besoin parce que
l'étape des déplacements entre les les
grosses boîtes et les labos ça
représente 3 % de la totalité du trafic
3% sait rien de ses pilotes ce cas si
les entreprises se mobilisent au temps
énorme et la réserve ya quelqu'un
demandez leur territoire les entreprises
se sont installées là à bon compte
parce que le territoire était mal
desservies maintenant ils réclament des
transports ça déjà c'est fort mal au cul
pour se développer pour se développer
puisque les entreprises
il ya des sites existants mais il ya
parfois des besoins de cils réseau
élargi jeu comme des gens qui
s'installent au bord d'un aéroport et
qui après c'est plein que c'était
bruyant sommes là je pense vraiment que
ces entreprises là et elles ont choisi
notre territoire
saint quentin alors oui les gens choisis
parce qu'il veut leur offrir le meilleur
envie aussi pour son camp 7 mai et en
leur offrant le meilleur environnement
possible pour se développer
c'est dans l'intérêt de notre territoire
parce qu'on aura plus de richesses et
aussi des salariés qui sont une vraie
demande là dessus est vraiment paris
saclay on n'a pas l'air d'être d'accord
mais pour moi c'est le sujet important à
venir pour l'excellence française pour
rayonner dans le monde ca faut arrêter
on a besoin de silicon valley à la
française pour réunir tout le monde sait
que cette icône valley à la française et
de la bêtise monumentale d'éternuements
de jeu les vérifier mais experts et à
l'étranger on m'a dit d'abord
d'excellents nicolas d'avis une question
on améliore le réseau de transport mais
alors est-ce qu'on voit loin dans
l'avenir on anticipe avec des projets
conséquents comme cette ligne 18 ou
est-ce qu'on est plus dans l'instantané
est-ce qu'on investit aujourd'hui en
plus dans les transports existants
toutes les innovations en matière de
transport sont bonnes à prendre
mais c'est insuffisant et je pense que
tous les territoires essaye d'innover et
celle de proposer des des transports
commun en site propre des solutions de
covoiturage
d
pistes cyclables toutes ces mesures va
si on essaye d'être prise mais c'est
insuffisant donc il faut une nouvel
équipement d'envergure
parce que rien n'a été fait depuis la
création de la ville nouvelle
d'envergure
il faut montrer que nos territoires de
rouge est d'ailleurs lieu est-ce qu'il
faut passer d'une desserte de quelques
centaines de personnes par heure à 4000
et est-ce qu'il ya pas une juste mesure
parce que la question est très
intéressante c'est en fait on est en
train de se dire mettre des milliards
pour avoir un transport en commun en
2030 au détriment des millions qu'on
pourrait mettre pour avoir demain
après-demain faire un couloir de bus sur
la d36 ou à côté de la d36 cd millions
et c'est des années et on n'est pas en
train de parler deux milliards et de
là on est en train de parler d'un métro
de 2030 c'est en égrenant toutes les
innovations mener son sang sont pas à la
hauteur de l'enjeu de paris saclay pour
lequel je bois auquel je crois et pour
les entreprises et l'innovation
les enquêtes de satisfaction allez-vous
un salarié qui ne peuvent plus de ces
embouteillages convient que ce soit plus
pratique pour aller leur domicile à leur
travail mais est ce que vous proposez
vous pour les entrepreneurs
mais il convient d'être lié en ligne ce
n'est pas une manière grâce à ces
problèmes c'est très intense ce n'est
pas une réponse à ce problème là ce
qu'il faut c'est une desserte de
proximité
les dessertes de loin en loin ça n'a
aucun intérêt au contraire aggrave la
l'étalement urbain alors et c'est de ça
que olivier paraître effectivement aux
désaccords puisqu'on n'a pas les mêmes
ambitions déjà sur le yen de paris
saclay c'est vrai que pour ceux qui
croient en ce projet cette ligne 18 elle
est fondamentale pour ceux qui n'en rama
c'est pas vrai effectivement et qui ne
défendent pas les salariés
du territoire pour le portis c'est pas
suffire les salariés du territoire ils
font ces sujets importants
je comprends vos l'édition mais s'il
peut intervenir un peu si la ligne
visitez était aussi importante que ça il
faudrait faire quelque chose qui soit là
beaucoup plus rapidement parce que
laisser juger en question ils vont voir
yvan poireauter pendant une dizaine
d'années si c'est pas plus parce que on
se focalise là sur 2030 mais c'est en
réalité 2035 si ça se faisait donc si
c'était aussi important que ça il
faudrait trouver un autre moyen pour
aller beaucoup plus vite fait on se bat
tous sur le calendrier
ceux qui vont s'implanter là pendant
pendant l'intervalle ils vont ils vont
être très très embêté parce qu'ils n'ont
pas de moyens mais les routes sont
saturés quand vous dites donc c'est
qu'il est grand l'exemple de ce qu'ils
nous disent c'est qu'ils raisonnent
effectivement à long terme donc ils
choisissent un territoire projeté je
projetais posément ils vont disparaître
et ils vont déménager ailleurs puisque
justement ils ont parfaitement à notre
époque on déménage très facilement
entier scission de l'ira tétouan le
technocentre dont il ya une histoire on
claque pas des doigts pour déménager des
milliers de salariés 18 km de rails 61%
en souterrain et 39% en aérien et seb
dans cette position cette portion pardon
aérienne qui pose problème dont une
partie en viaduc 14 km entre 7 7 à 11
mètres de haut
pourquoi ça dérange ce dérangeant c'est
pas le propre problème principal pour
moi c'est pas le problème principal que
ce soit en arrière ou en souterrain dans
tous les cas de figure ce sera un
facilitateur un formidable générateur
d'étalement urbain
ça va finir comme disait roger olivier
préparé à ça va finir pas bétonner tout
le plateau de saclay sayada peut-être
qu'ils veulent ça ça existe je sais mais
c'est pas dans l'intérêt général
il faudrait que les gens regardent
l'intérêt général plutôt que les
intérêts particuliers de tel ou telle
entreprise pour moi l'intérêt
elle c'est de réussir paris saclay et
c'est pas une bétonisation et ce n'est
pas la ligne à 18 me soit arrivée
tration de l'excellence il doit donc
offert et servi pour faire réussir
parisien acquérir l'intérêt général
l'intérêt général est ce que c'est de
mettre 3 milliards pour une desserte
qu'on estime à peu près à 100 mille
personnes par jour où c'est m 3
milliards pour par exemple prolonger le
rer e entre saint-lazare et la défense
qui va concerner 400 mille personnes ou
mettons les milliards et moi
personnellement je pense qu'il faut
mettre des millions demain demain dès
2018 sur des transports en commun pour
les problèmes je suis complètement
d'accord sur le fait qu'aujourd'hui il
ya des salariés qui souffrent des
embouteillages qui s'ouvre ne pas avoir
de transport en commun efficace mais
mais ne leur promettons pas quelque
chose de mirifiques et de
surdimensionner pour dans dix ans
nicolas naville quelle réponse vous
apportez à à 7 cette problématique
autour des impacts que cette ligne pour
avoir sur le bassin agricole déjà sur
les formes il ya d'autres études qui
conteste ce chiffre et qui maintenant
qu'il est sous-estimé regarde les études
sur le bassin agricole
moi je défends bien évidemment le
maintien d'un certain nombre de terres
agricoles une agriculture de proximité
c'est très important c'est on a les
essonne et le vietnam deux magnifiques
département c'est un peu le poumon vert
de de l'île de france je pense que tout
le monde est d'accord pour ça et pour
moi justement c'est pour ça qu'il faut
le train c'est que le train n'est pas
polluant donc le train ne ne pollue pas
ses terres
et cet environnement c'est tout pour moi
si je peux me permettre si je peux me
permettre juste un dernier argument pour
monsieur paréja regarder ce qui se passe
à paris alors vous me direz c'est juste
pas de votre responsabilité mais à force
de développer des espaces pour les vélos
ou pour un certain nombre de deux bus
on est en train de créer des bouchons
monstres on voit ce qui se passe sur le
périphérique
donc moi je pense que c'est pas du tout
la solution mais les tcsp
je pense qu'on peut émettre un certain
nombre de réserves sur l'utilité
toujours de ce mode de transport il faut
les développer mais le train permet de
manière propre de bien desservir ces
territoires et et tout ce qui était csp
et kid 2 mais cette manière de réduire
nos routes
sacré de la congestion terrible qui crée
un ras-le-bol et sans précédent des
usagers qui utilisent la voiture donc il
faut il faut qu'on soit et moi je pense
que c'est une manière même écologique de
répondre à ce problème de congestion
c'est de développer cette ligne de train
écologiste le prolongement de la ligue
18 il va pas justement polluer final
c'est donc il ya d'autres solutions il
ya d'autres solutions
aujourd'hui par exemple pour relier orly
massy versailles il ya les projets qui
sont plus ou moins à arrêter relancer je
sais pas exactement de d'amélioration de
la ligne c2 du rer c et c ces lignes la
qui existent déjà que l'on les rendre
plus efficaces qu'on les rende plus
dense en fréquentation et qu'on la
prolonge jusqu'à saint quentin en
yvelines par exemple sur le coeur de
saint quentin en yvelines c'est à dire
qu'il y avait moi ça aurait moins
d'impact
bien entendu celle en fait la desserte
du plateau de saclay quand on regarde le
plateau de saclay il y à quelques
centres de recherche qui sont installés
dessus mais la plupart des habitants
sont plutôt dans les vallées sur le côté
donc où d'un côté on a le rer b qui va
jusqu'à saint rémy et de l'autre côté on
a le rer c qui peut très bien faire orly
orly massy versailles et saint quentin
et on pourrait très bien arriver à d
efficacité de desserte c'est-à-dire à
l'est de saint quentin à orly ou de
versailles à orly si c'est si important
que ça d'aller à l'aéroport on pourrait
on pourrait sur des tanks qui sont qui
sont similaires
la façon dont la société du grand paris
nous vend la ligne 18 et complètement
biaisé puisque elle nous compare à
l'infrastructure d'aujourd'hui alors que
on est en train de développer des choses
comme cette ligne c du rer ou où on
pourrait aussi densifier le rer b à
saint rémy il ya d'autres solutions
alternatives beaucoup moins coûteuse et
là je le redis on parle de millions
plutôt que une ligne qui n'a pas
vraiment d'utilité une ligne de métro
qui passe au milieu des champs ça sera
une grande innovation effectif
un métro qui passe au milieu des champs
avec une si faible densité des
populations
c'est une première mondiale quand il
fait tout dépend et la scission de
l'ambition qu'on a je tiens à vous dire
que quand à leur pathologie letra le
grand paris express
il va consommer autant d'énergie que il
la ville de rennes
c'est à dire qu'ils doublent la
consommation électrique de tout le
réseau francilien
bon ben je regrette et vous apprécierez
cool aux attentes de discours qu'ils
sont dans la critique permanente
on peut pas être écologie bah oui parce
que c'est le trait légiste et rien ne
pas défendre le train qui est pour moi
un des moyens dans les sports les plus
écologiques existent dans le mode co op
l'inutile on peut pas gagner ligne qu'il
le sien - de logements en ile de france
puisque c'est un comme des combats qui
me donne un concert de logements et ne
pas vouloir en importe les desservir
alors mais si on peut très bien que dans
dans l'essonne il va y avoir un certain
nombre de constructions de logements
dans les îles
c'est un passant qui fait aussi six
places et laminé démission je peux me
permettre juste c'est dans la ville
nouvelle de construire des logements on
a à peu près mille 100 logements par an
et puis depuis 2012 donc par là la voix
ces gens là on nage ici je vais vous
donner la parole qu'on réponde à ce
qu'on fait sur le territoire on va
conclure je vais vous donner la parole
chacun très rapidement cette ligne 18 et
ce qu'elle peut participer selon vous au
rayonnement de la région parle de trois
départements traversés dix communes
desservies plus d'attractivité de
mobilité d'urbanisation risque ou
aubaine 30 secondes chacun séparés alors
moi je pense que c'est un risque c'est à
dire que répondre aux vrais besoins des
habitants
continuer à développer le bassin de
saint quentin versailles qui est une une
réussite
en ile de france au sens distance entre
les les là où les gens travaillent là où
les gens habitent
ça c'est des choses qui sont des vraies
réussites et qu'il faut continuer et
qu'il faut encourager et continuer à
urbaniser c'est un vrai risque c'est un
vrai risque qui ne va pas du tout dans
le sens d'une d'une planète qui qu'ils
puissent demain encore nous accueillir
il faut continuer à garder des terres
agricoles de proximité
nicolas n'a rien coûté il faut qu'on se
batte sur cette ligne 18 pour réussir
paris saclay pour permettre aux
entreprises de se développer sur notre
territoire c'est important et petit
regret que je suis un petit peu déçu de
l'attitude des écologistes français
parce que c'est justement je pense un
magnifique moyens propres de desservir
notre territoire plutôt que créer des
bouchons monstres comme on le voit
aujourd'hui à paris avec avec le ce qui
se passe sur le périphérique en petite
couronne et les premières lignes de
métro qui sont en train d'être
développés sont extrêmement importantes
et il faut les faire mais par contre la
ligne 17 ou la ligne 18 qui sont des
lignes au nord est la nôtre la cd ligne
qui sont surdimensionnés et donc les
écologistes sont économes aussi en
dépenses publiques et en dépenses
agrégation de l'ambition pour notre
territoire donc je je veux dire que la
ligne 18 ne correspond pas le résout pas
le problème de desserte qui existe
aujourd'hui et toutes les les arguments
qui ont été avancés par monsieur de la
ville sont faux et son ourson sont de
l'ordre de l'incantation que je ne
partage pas bien sûr parce que dire que
paris saclay ça va être la silicon
valley à la française
tout le monde est d'accord que ses
soutiens américains pour vous il n'ya
aucune sur le côté ligne 18
non non il faut d'autres il faut
d'autres moyens pour résoudre les
problèmes des dessertes locales et une
desserte de loin en loin ça n'a aucun
intérêt
c'est contre-productif ça va augmenter
l'étalement urbain et ça n'a pas
d'intérêt pour les minis pour les
entreprises parce que toute façon on va
pas faire la pendule entre entre saclay
à qantas c'est une ânerie de dire ça et
c'est pas non plus les quelques
étudiants qui vont aller de 50 à saclay
tout ça c'est un trafic proche de zéro
donc tout ça cela ne justifie en aucune
façon une ligne et capacitaires sur le
plateau de ce qu'il faut développer ce
sont les transports locaux et non pas
les transports distants merci à tous les
trois c'est la fin de cette émission fin
de 7,8 débat consacré à la ligne 18 ce
soir du grand paris express
l'émission est à revoir sur notre site
internet a commenté sur les réseaux
sociaux
bonne soirée à tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]